y
este es una tarde de domingo en la
ciudad de odessa donde la vida ha ido
cambiando radicalmente en las últimas
semanas este fin de semana ha habido una
iniciativa de la sociedad para hacer
actos culturales como pacto de
resistencia a la guerra frente a mí hay
uno de los grupos de teatro más
importantes de la ciudad están leyendo
obras de uno de los humoristas más
importantes de ucrania y como vemos aquí
está un grupo de la población
disfrutando de esta tarde primaveral en
este mercadillo que es uno de los más
tradicionales del centro de la ciudad
acá en librerías hay que hay cafés y a
pesar de que hace unos días estaba todo
cerrado ahora vuelve a estar abierto
como muchos de los restaurantes o muchas
de estas galerías que poco a poco la
gente que se ha quedado desafía el temor
a pesar de que anoche hubo alarmas en la
madrugada pero esa certeza de que las
tropas rusas que estaban en las
cercanías de mykolaiv a 135 kilómetros
de aquí han ido retrocediendo y que los
barcos pues han ido también perdiendo su
capacidad de atacar a la ciudad esto ha
ido cambiando el ambiente y el
sentimiento de la población